this podcast is brought to you by raycon
earbuds my friends my lovely genius
praying listeners we are officially in a
dupe session and raycon wireless earbuds
are some dupes that are amazing that you
should definitely not sleep on because
we want some premium quality stuff
without having to pay the premium price
raycon earbuds my friends have three
customizable sound profiles earbud tab
functions noise isolation and so much
more if you want a cop a pair go to buy
raycon.com spray today to get 50 off
your raycon order that's Buy raycon.com
Brandon scored 15 off that's by
raycon.com brain
my lovely genius farts you sexy Sean the
most seconds it has finally dropped one
week left to cop the pre-orders for the
anime inspired genius brain secret
society collab piece if you're just
finding out about this right now you got
seven more days over size fit 100 cotton
Jersey tea with puff print details on
the front and the back so many people
make cheap anime inspired shirts and
they straight funny look weird they have
an outfit and they just don't care but
not us this is my Ode to something that
I love as a kid and I still love as an
adult and people are just catching on to
this anime wave but guess what my
friends you don't have to wear crappy
anime teas don't miss out seven more
days to cop this piece and its first
come first serve uh for shipping so get
on it it's going to be at
secretsociety.com that's
www.scrts-o-c-i-e-t-y.com seven more
days for the pre-orders cop it first
come first served once again love you
bye
yesterday we were talking and then she
said that I I she thinks but the next
session we're going to talk about is
more but the things that I have autistic
tendencies
like one thing is called um
restricted
hey uh my name is Jason and I'm here and
I want to talk about my feelings in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we have this
hold on a second first of all I just
want to put this out there
I have not been sharing this on my feed
but I don't understand why the algorithm
keeps showing me kids with Down Syndrome
is because you watch it every time no I
don't know you watch it every day people
some people send this to me and they
tell me to laugh and I don't laugh you
send it to yourself nobody's sending it
to you David I stop lying to your people
I have an archive where I saved about 30
of them you send it to yourself listen
there's this video that I I always feel
weird about sharing with people because
I don't want to be judged yeah but they
are also in the joke and they they I
think they made this video is this one
video called chromosome man
it's
this kid who has Down syndrome that he's
going to save people he's in a Superman
suit he's in a Superman suit yeah but he
keeps [__] things up because he has
Down syndrome and he presses a button he
explodes and he kills people yeah I
didn't make that video yeah so I it's
okay if I laugh yeah
it's me yes
listen you
of the only reason okay let me just put
this out here right I just want this
this episode is just me confronting my
abuser
here's the thing so [__] digging into
my garbage can it was really
uncomfortable
um
it was really uncomfortable though when
you saw it because last time I had
some garbage okay yeah and then so I
opened your garbage can yeah it was this
before or after when I came over it was
before so this full the last before the
last time this fool was on my podcast
right
most people when they come here this is
what happens they text me they go where
do I go they go from their car straight
to the studio
I'm wondering where this guy's at he
says he's here I don't see him so I walk
outside and I see this this man
digging into my garbage can and I'm like
that can't be that can't be Jason
because he's a normal person how come
every time I come here you're outside
already how do you know I'm just there
because I could smell you you stinky
piece of [__] dude
why were you dig into my garbage can
okay it's because I had a trash okay
uh-huh and then I didn't want to startle
you because I didn't get into your house
yet so I was like I don't want to like
alarm him
that's what's happening yeah I don't
want to make a noise
don't hit the bathroom
I just see this guy half his body is
into my garbage inside the garbage this
is what I thought you were doing I
thought that you were gonna you were
trying to hide in there to scare me what
like you were gonna go into the garbage
shed and text me and be like hey dude go
take out your trash and I'm like why
should I just pop out you're just there
for an hour because I'm not going
outside
you're a piece of [__] oh wow that's the
only reason why I brought you on here
today just to let you know you're a
[__] piece of [__] all right I just
wanted to be a good citizen and not um
startle you that's all so Jason and okay
you know what this is another thing I
want to say this I try to throw so I I
ate uh a day just now date is good for
your intestines and stuff there's a seed
I try to find a trash can in your second
house the house that's next to your
house right and then there's the trash
can I open it there's no garbage bag and
what did I say there's trash inside the
garbage I told you I figured it out and
there's trash inside of garbage and you
said to throw it in just the empty
garbage but there's only five piece of
trash there's like a wiped toilet paper
and like an apple apple sauce thing I
have never been assaulted for caring
about the Earth
I don't use Plastics okay oh did you
really I just used the plastic bin and I
just throw it into the garbage out there
because I care about the Earth but
apparently that's just me really no you
idiot I'm lazy
I'm [__] lazy that was a very good
yeah that got me okay I really see a
[__] and every time I look at that
garbage can I realize that I have to Uno
I have to open a bag and I have to do
that stupid thing and then when you put
it in there's too much air and then you
have to press I don't want to do that
but that was you said to just put it in
there yeah and then we'll figure it out
yeah I always figure it out yeah it's
the exact opposite because there are
recyclable plastics in there and I just
ordered the garbage can
it's a terrible thing this man you know
if you guys remember the last time we
were on this podcast I explicitly told
this dude what's the problem and if he
wants to shoot a special right on his
own I am somebody who has been in video
I have done editing I have I have done
everything from the beginning to the
back end right shooting a special on a
small scale is easy work for me very
easy work and what the [__] did I tell
you okay I'm gonna tell you something
bro you shut the [__] up what the [__]
did I tell you to do before you shoot it
I know
I didn't even shoot it I just got a
camera and I could tell yeah you shot
that [__] literally on a potato
it was a good potato
it feels a good potato
okay here's the thing is because there's
a couple of things one I just because
you already
like I just don't want to because you
you like offered to do it and I don't
want it because I know you're busy and
also I really just don't want to um
take advantage because you already
support me in a lot of ways it takes
advantage of me all right I offered it
to you I know because I knew you were
gonna shoot some garbage like that yeah
I know I was so mad first of all you sh
why did you tell the person with the
camera you set up why did you set up why
did you set it up six miles away
hey Jason can you set a closer please
just yell at yourself hey you idiot why
did you [__] set it up so far I just
put it at a place that I'm like oh this
looks good
okay said what do you mean so far away I
zoomed in it it looked like somebody was
[__] they were gonna sell your [__]
on a DVD later
scalp your own [__] special out of
the streets in Hollywood and what kind
of shitty let me tell you something that
was Grassroots I go grass suits that was
Cemetery dude that was deep in the earth
that was straight up in the core of the
earth why the [__] I was but I was like
okay Jason did this special he he
probably has at least like I don't know
three angles is one angle
it's one angle on an iPhone 2
he had to buy one off of eBay just so he
could shoot this [__] video yeah I
was so mad and then he recorded it
through his [__] voice recorder
I actually did oh my God together with
the with the with the cell phone
honestly but I just wanted to do it
because um I really want people to come
out and see my stand-up live and you
know what the difference is I could have
shot that for you and it would have
taken literally no time out of my day no
but it would it's a thing you got it I
wouldn't do it and you got it I would
have got me my two camera dudes we would
have set it up we would have might you
up I'm not saying I would have edited it
I would have at least given you the
footage so you could give it to an
editor yeah and it literally takes
nothing out of me because I've got it so
many times places
and you gotta like do the thing and I'm
gonna feel bad because it's like you you
spending your time I mean and your
energy and I just I just feel bad
you're so Asian
yourself because you already do uh do
you already support me is the thing I
don't give a [__] I told you I listen we
could still do it but I just I'm not I
don't want you to like even saying that
we could still do it it makes me feel
bad honestly why why I told you I'll do
it I want to do it why do you want to do
it because I know how shitty you're
gonna do it
but then the thing is if you do it I
feel like I owe you so much you don't
already feel like you don't owe me [__]
yeah but the Asians out there they know
they they feel like you know somebody do
a nice thing you are so [__] you know
what I'm talking about you will feel the
same way if somebody do something for
you and I don't ask for help because I
can do everything all right
that's how I did it myself no no no
that's how I did it which is the thing
you can't do everything I did it you did
that that was not doing it now when I
turned that [__] on I was like oh this
is a special from 2001.
I said it didn't look good I was like
wow you you haven't aged at all it's
like that's pretty good well when I
uploaded I was like that's fine I just
want people to come see you and I
literally when I upload it I was like
I'm gonna take it down in like a month
dude the comments literally on your
[__] YouTube videos like he deserves
better
who would do this to him it's like me
who would do this and fire the
videographer you're like I can't it was
me
I can't fire myself
no I was so upset when I saw that [__] I
was like that's really nice
if I didn't set up multiple angles I
could have set up one camera and it's
still gonna look way better than that I
could have done one camera and just
lobbed you up and it would have been 10
times better yeah and it would have I
could have set it up and I could have
walked away and [__] had lunch and
came back and it would have been fine
yeah
that's why I was shocked I'm not a
professional at uh the video
photographer space
the next one you do yeah I'm going to
shoot it okay yeah okay that's easy [__]
you just gotta give me the date and the
time yeah I call my crew up yeah and
then we shoot it I'll give you the
footage and then I'll help you find an
editor that's it I'll buy lunch there
you go that's it you just buy me how do
you feel bad in my heart but thank you I
I'm gonna I'll I'll run it by you next
because the reason why I'm telling you I
can do this is because what's hard for
you is easy for me okay it's it's it's
so [__] easy it's unreal how easy oh
you know what this is really good to
know and now I feel better and I think
I'm going to now because like that's the
thing like when people some for some
people too like sometimes people feel
really bad asking because for me it will
be really hard and like for me it will
be like really agitating to film
somebody's thing uh and it would be
really difficult for me to do but it's a
little bit easier for you I know you
also trying to be polite and nice but
but yeah but that makes me feel a little
bit better it's so easy for me right so
when I see
because I know because you're like a
traditional traditional comic right yeah
traditional Comics can't do anything but
make jokes and make people laugh which
is the greatest thing ever right for me
I what started in video and then I
transitioned the other way around right
so recording things setting things up
right getting all this other [__] it's
my it's my [__] like it's not hard like
honestly if I said [__] all this other
stuff I could apply to a job somewhere
and literally doing video work and I'll
get that job wow that's how good I am at
my [__] yeah like even this podcast
right when I every podcast that you've
seen that other people have done usually
doesn't look that great because I'm not
the one editing it but every podcast
that I've edited like for example like
the recent ones everybody's having seen
and I've read comments like oh who's
doing your stuff I went back to editing
my own [__] because nobody cares about
the stuff uh as much as I do when it
comes to my work right yeah and a lot of
it's about style and taste yeah so for
you if you're ready to do redo your
special and you want to take that
garbage down yeah I do I was going to I
I really I just wanted some people to
see it and they go oh I want to go and
see him because also too like one of the
things that you you didn't do or maybe
you don't realize is that you know
obviously when people shoot they're
special whether it goes on YouTube or
not we're going to set it up probably in
the same location and you're gonna do
three or four nights in a row and then
we're gonna chop it up okay right
because your delivery will be different
on certain days sometimes you'll you'll
you'll Riff Off The Crowd differently
and we want to keep those pieces in so
we have to record it three or four times
over okay and then we just need you to
wear the same clothes three days in a
row yeah and then we chop it up and get
the best bits nothing on Netflix none of
that special is done in one night yeah
oh yeah I know yeah it's like five or so
it's like four or five nights it's a lot
yeah and they just wear the same [__]
and they just chop it up yeah they get
some of the Dead air out and that's why
they have multiple angles when you shoot
one thing it's because when we're
shooting these things right we're trying
to make people feel like how it feels
like in the crowd because when you watch
stand up on screen you don't get to feel
the energy you don't get to feel the
energy that's where the editing and how
it shot it comes in yeah right because
everybody in the crowd is laughing but
when you watch it from a distance you
have to kind of try to imagine yourself
there yeah when you shoot it well you
don't have to do that right we get the
audio from the crowd we bump up the
laughs a little bit we make it sound
really good just as it would not it's
not a lie it's just making it sound how
it is if you were there yeah if you were
there that that's that's very well uh
explained like there's one angle that I
didn't really see until Shane Gillis is
special it's like an angle like in the
actually in the crowd like they will
have like over the shoulder of a person
of an audience member seeing Shannon and
I love that because it really makes you
feel like you're you're not it's it's
impossible to replicate that feeling
watching something live but when I saw
that I was like oh man I would love that
angle I might think but you know 100 and
we need like the the crowd reaction all
that other stuff right we need to see
when you when you improv and you talk to
the crowd you might want to keep that
into the special that's not a part of
your set so we need to get the crowd
reaction with that there's just a whole
bunch of things also too like I've
it's fun for me yeah I mean like it's
it's really fun for me and there are
other people who I have offered this to
but I don't believe in them that much
and they passed and I was like go get
better
don't waste my time with this all right
yeah you don't even make me laugh yeah
can you make multiple people laugh
they all stopped doing comedy
but for you I'm excited because now it's
like on my end I'm like okay this is
going to be really fun because who knows
maybe when I shoot mine I get to
practice with you and then I'm learning
along the way too that'll be cool yeah
but I'm telling you then you're gonna
start doing it or what man don't don't
[__] yell at me all right
don't yell at me you said this summer I
just want to let everybody do not see
those Tomatoes I'm growing right now all
right do you want me to neglect the
tomatoes I put all my energy into it how
come you got into the uh Botanical thing
first I don't know what boot tactical is
it's scary gardening
all right
is when I scare my tomatoes alive
if you don't know this about me I'm a
[__] odd human being
when I you never did this before I when
I get into something I get into it a
little too much like it becomes very
very very obsessive yeah right so I've
had two years where I did tomatoes and
they failed on me two years two years of
my life when two the last two summers in
a row yeah oh failed miserably and it's
been eating away at me I don't like
losing oh wow all right this year look
at those [__] dude this [__]
got a whole force of potatoes because
you said you were scared that some of
them was gonna die I germinated 72
plants
and alternated and then I just was like
they're all here what do I do with 72
[__] Tomatoes yeah but so instead I
gave away a lot a lot of them died but
I've kept a few and now I'm doing this
Farm project with a bunch of friends of
mine I basically went from the age 35 to
86.
and this is my life now wait what do you
mean Farm project so everybody knows
that I really love food right I [__]
hate you dude okay okay let's say this
so I'm trying to do this Farm project
where I it's permaculture right you you
basically you you eat what you sow this
is when you know jumbi matcha is doing
great
that is planting potatoes or tomatoes
every day just getting into it Chase is
like okay I have been grinding my ass
off killing myself going on garbage
specials because I got no other options
planting tomatoes
for two years I've landed tomatoes and
it didn't grow so guess what this third
year I'm gonna get these Tomatoes all
right my life is hard man [__] my life
is so hard Doug okay tomatoes so I'm
doing this permaculture thing
Lizzy long story short right
chickens yeah
um
bug larvae that feeds the chickens the
chickens give us eggs we eat the eggs
that in turn gives us fertilizer we
compost it we put it back into the
plants we reswed the seed so everything
is free right so this is the most Asian
thing ever I don't ever want to pay for
that ever yeah right yeah and so we're
doing this thing at my buddy's house and
we're redoing his whole backyard his
name is Robin so he is me times 30. like
he's wildly obsessive right so I just
take a little bit of his insanity and
apply it to my life so my stuff is like
this he has like literally 40 tomato
plants well how do you find uh he only
has Tomatoes no we were doing everything
we're doing like herb garden and so
right now we're how did you find this
person we met each other through food
because he he did this thing called
little meets La where we would take he
would take chefs who you know they work
in kitchens and whatever whatnot but
they don't get to work on their own
menus because they don't have their own
uh restaurant yeah so we would set these
he would set these dinner parties where
basically it would be like 10 people
would come and the chef gets to explain
every dish they make wow so so I met him
through that and we did our own little
thing and now we're doing this well what
did he say because you met him through
the the chef saying stuff course meal
thing what did he say that you're like
man I want to befriend him
um
he's kind of nuts
like like he's been on this podcast
before but uh okay but I'll tell you
like he hasn't told these stories right
but like just for example I think he's
broken his forearms like three or four
times just for Mortal cycling accidents
oh my God like he has like a missing
shade finger because when he flew off
the [__] motorcycle like his hand
grazed across the floor when he was
skipping like a [__] like a river
rock
he grinded his [__] finger down
and so it's just a nub and a little baby
nail oh my God if you look into his arms
like there's two major scars from when
he broke both of his forearms and I saw
a photo of him in the hospital bed just
like back in the movies like in the like
in the movies that's crazy he's [__]
nuts okay so he is I I took that
inspiration and applied it to my life
yeah that's a lot that that when it's
something somebody's really extreme it
really interests me as well well I just
like I get into like weird hobbies and
stuff like that so this needs to
complete this year because if not I'm
never gonna do stand up
like I'm working on material all the
time but the most of the time is spent
on the tomatoes right now yeah yeah and
you see how healthy they are they seem
cute don't know they're healthy all
right okay I'll beat your ass don't
disrespect my tomatoes
foreign
they're [__] healthy as [__] and
they're strong and robust
you have no idea last year I grew four
tomato plants right guess how many
tomatoes I got none half of one
one little baby ass tomato I divided
that [__] into like eight pieces to save
it because I was so sad
it was the saddest thing I've ever done
I'm gonna use it I froze it I was like
oh dude December
um I'm a winner I called it my trauma
tomato
wait wait wait these are the big ones or
the small ones they're multiple ones so
I'm growing um black princes
um big rainbows uh beef steaks pink
brandy wines uh Sun Golds momotaros Snow
Whites and also
do you think do you think you're a
little bit autistic
because I relate
this is why people
Jonathan I watched the videos I'm like I
belong
but you know like I I told the story
remember I told you like I my best
friends growing up in elementary school
were the kids in the special class oh
yeah yeah I didn't know okay let me ask
you well okay and I want to talk about
this but well the special class how come
you befriended them because you think
they're talented they tricked me with
snacks
I'm not even lying dude that is are you
they checked it was that what do you
mean that was a kid okay
come tell the story again and you guys
if there's new listeners but
there was a kid whose parents owned like
like a liquor store or whatever whatnot
right and look when you're a kid you
just enjoy people's presents yeah right
and you don't know if you're doing
something weird I'm not looking at color
or anything else like that I'm just
looking at people who Treat Me Nice and
there wasn't a lot of people at the time
and so there's this one kid his name was
used to always have these Funyuns and he
would always share them with me and so
we bonded because you know he would give
me [__] Funyuns and [__] oh that's
nice super [__] nice yeah but then
you know people will try to punk him and
I'm a big kid I was like this size when
I was six oh damn right so I would tell
people to leave them alone so this kid
who was in like in the special class
somehow used me with snacks for
protection he feeds you he feeds the
monster me yeah
I protect you you don't touch it
he give me food
and so I actually didn't know
this kid was like you know different and
the only way I found out was actually
when I was in in um in [__] high
school where I saw him and he was still
dressed in the same clothes basically
the style of clothes that he was wearing
when he was in elementary school he used
to get punked a lot because he used to
dress up like a PeeWee Herman like the
bow tie and like the suit and stuff and
like suspenders oh wow well he was
dressed like that as an adult in high
school and then it clicked I was like
well it took you that long I didn't know
because I moved schools
so it was all the way till I was like in
third grade which I probably should have
figured it out by then yeah yeah but I
didn't next thing you know I see him as
adult I'm like oh my God he's special oh
okay and he was one of my best friends
and I had no [__] idea happened twice
it was two kids but I was just kidding
with the kids in the special class I had
no [__] idea that's what I'm saying
I'm a good person
well you didn't know you were
all right
I I asked you so I have a psychiatrist
uh and I she yesterday we were talking
and then she said that I I she thinks
but the next session we're going to talk
about it some more but she thinks that I
have autistic tendencies
like the one thing is called um
restricted
hey uh my name is Jason and I'm here and
I want to talk about my feelings well
let's start with your brain first
I think you're autistic oh
yeah why did you talk about that
that's a good point dude I'm gonna ask
you next time this is not your job [__]
it's like hey [__]
I like to talk about my family trauma
how dare you
like I'm talking about my dad she's like
are you [__]
I'm like what do you mean
she's just what the [__]
hey here's some blocks this is a circle
see let's see where this bot fits into
this thing oh that's so fun wait why did
she bring that up
um or just some of the things that I say
and she's like oh like these things are
like Tendencies and I was like hey do
you think maybe I'm on the Spectrum and
she's like yeah some of them is uh she's
like we'll talk about it some more at
the thing and then um because one thing
there's two things I do one one is that
uh like I I really don't have interests
like a lot of interest like it's called
restricted interest that's one of the
tendencies that if you're on the
Spectrum that's one of the things so
it's like you know how you have many
interests and I get so like whatever
you're interested I may not be
interested like sports I cannot like
I I like experiences but I just are very
disinterested that it hurts like if you
say like um like tomatoes are actually
cool because I never actually like know
about it like that piques my interest a
bit but if it's something that I know of
and I just are not interested in it
hurts to like
do like talk about the thing or be
around the thing like the the feeling is
just more extreme than normal people
like so like when you're so like the
first time you ever had sex with your
wife you're just like it's okay
I mean do we have to because how was it
you're like it's okay
I'm autistic
we have to do it every day yeah
or do you want to so much
I'm tired let's do something else it's
not even working have you tried growing
tomatoes
or the middle of having sex
well I had never heard of that [__] yeah
it's restricted interest that's one
thing and then another thing is like I
like to listen to music like one song
for a while and when I say a while it
would be like this one song that I like
right now
ABCs autistic
but anyways I don't know what I talked
about it but anyways yeah but I I well
okay let's say there's like a song that
you really really [__] like right
yeah how long will you listen to it for
I live so I I was traveling and I maybe
with the travel time was like 12 hours I
listened to it the whole day one song
I'll just put the earplugs in what the
Yeah on repeat I love it it's so good 12
hours what's the song There's a um I'll
tell you it's by Lee Hong Yi it's uh I
think still loves you you [__] you
know that one Chinese [__] no no that
it's a Korean song dude I don't know who
the [__] that is dude it's a Korean song
that he belts it
um
do you know what I'm talking about
but I want to hear still love you
[Music]
are you crying while you're driving for
12 hours no this is a good one it's
Claudia you know this song
you're for sure on the Spectrum
why are you listening to a song that you
should be listening to in the rain as
you're as a person you love is in your
arms I do I pour water were you crying
when you listen to that song no I I'm
like enjoying I enjoying the melody you
listen to that song for that long yeah
and multiple days I've been listening to
this song for like like two months now
two three months because God damn yeah I
like it like that and the song before
this was Rihanna's uh what was that one
this
is the loved one that's okay that's okay
what the how am I supposed to know that
[__] okay but anyways I just do one song
for like you listen to this okay you
know what you're also finding out about
yourself because of that you're also gay
[Laughter]
the problem is you have a wife and a kid
what
that's the problem I love them
but I'm not sure
when I see her I go I don't know
[Laughter]
crazy yeah I'm just finding this out
myself too it's news to the both of us
you're just like what the [__] wait you
you never thought it was weird though
that you could only listen to like a
single song for that long I just thought
some people like one song and oh yeah
because you wouldn't really think that's
weird if you just enjoying yourself yeah
I'm having a good time is the thing but
do you not like that do do you not
listen I mean there's like a song that I
really like right now that I [__] with
really heavy but I've listened to it for
maybe the past couple of days but I'm
listening to it while listening to other
songs though oh okay you know what I'm
saying like it's not like I listen to
that song and something else comes on I
go
I don't do that what you do is that what
you do that I'll be like ah I don't
wanna you start screaming
I feel like that's what happens dude
that's so weird yeah that's pretty weird
you know what's even weirder your wife
probably knew this about you and she
still said I guess I love him
she's crazy let me tell you something I
thank her every day the more I discover
about myself the more I'm like thank you
so much
please don't leave me ever yeah please
don't I sometimes look at my wife even
in the morning when she has boogers all
over her face I'm like I can't do any
better than this there's no way she's
way above me yeah she hasn't figured it
out yet yeah I always act like I don't
need her but I really do
if she leaves me I'm [__] yeah I'm
[__] how sad would you be oh I'd be so
[__] sad I guarantee you I probably
won't date for like another like six
seven years yeah it's just she knows
everything about me you know what I mean
yeah and she's dealt with all the weird
like for example she'll ask me some [__]
right well she'll be like okay hey I'm
really want to go hiking in the morning
it's going to be around like 7 A.M and
I'm like
tired like it's just too hard and then
she sees me wake up at 6am
um
these tomatoes and then I'm like
gardening in my sun hat and my gloves
and I look up and I just see her through
the blinds like this
it's just a [__] pissed she goes oh
you'll wake up for [__] Tomatoes but
you can't go hiking with me in the
morning are you serious I have nothing
to say because I'm wrong because I'm
wrong but she hasn't divorced me
who's who's gonna do this who who else
is gonna deal with this [__] there's
nobody there's literally no I I
sometimes look at myself and I go dude
you're dumb why can't you just be a
normal person
I can't believe this tomato thing but
that is so funny though because she said
you wake up at six
the tomatoes I'm like I'll even look at
myself in the mirror sometimes like okay
the other day she she came in I said
this happened this was two [__]
moments where I was like dude I'm
hideous like I came into the house I had
my gardening gloves my sunglasses and my
straw hat right and she just goes yuck
and at first I was a little pissed at
first because that was super unnecessary
especially when you just walk into the
house and that's the first thing you
hear from them like yuck I'm like that's
really offensive and I go into the the
bathroom to wash up because I'm hella
pissed but then I look at myself and I
go I understand I get this so right
where we live right now our neighbors
have like two really like attractive
girls that live there right
doesn't mean anything I'm married who
the [__] cares yeah here's the problem
though I'm not that much older than them
right okay not that much right maybe six
seven years whatever okay
I'm outside and I'm guarding you know in
my orange shorts yeah and then my ocean
shirt and then my son hat and gloves I'm
out there I see them and I go good
morning and they go good morning sir sir
what the [__] [__] sir
you're not that much older than you she
[__] called me sir
your energy has transformed man you
can't be doing tomatoes and do the thing
and the glove and the thing and then not
be calls her it's too hard to try to be
attractive
it is
it is you gotta do your hair you have to
[__] uh brush your teeth
Mario just just just do it
just do it just leave
you get out of here dude there's this
Reddit thread do it while he's doing the
tomatoes
I come into the house everything's gone
she goes it's beer the tomatoes
I get so sad sometimes because like
I I understand
it's just very hard to like care about
like your physical well-being a lot you
know what I mean are you doing it right
now it's nice
yeah I'd like look it's just when I see
other people and they and they leave the
house and they go what do I what do I
have to wear oh this is gonna look whack
oh I gotta make I don't think about any
of that stuff I don't even look in the
mirror
you don't look in America I only notice
this not too long ago because she
mentioned it she goes do you ever just
before you walk out just look at the
mirror I'm like yeah sorry dude [__]
this is July [__] in my teeth there's
like eye boogers here there's like
earwax coming out
and then she goes dude what the [__] are
you doing like look at the mirror before
you leave the house I was like you
[__] married me like I'm not the
weird one you knew about this and you
still said it but okay let me ask you
when you when you were going out with
her in the beginning did you like like
try to look nice like brush your teeth I
probably did that's what I'm saying but
I think it's nice because I do this [__]
too only when I go out like to see
people would I shower do my hair at home
I'm I'm [__] I'm I look I look like
this seriously that was very unnecessary
like whatever this is I look similar not
like this exactly but almost there you
know what the surprising thing is I
actually did shower
this is what I this is what I look like
all right I was on uh tigerbelly the
other day and I had to do uh headshots
before I came in but so I just knocked
it out in one go because where I had to
go was close to that area that he shoots
his podcast yeah so okay let's just
shoot it here instead of uh on Friday so
but you know when you're doing headshots
you're actually getting your [__] done
yeah right I [__] use lotion on my
face yeah I did my hair I brought out
the clothes that I never wear
and then they were just like who the
[__] are they yeah are you like what's
going on and I'm like that's so sad that
when I just dress like a normal human
they think somebody died yeah yeah are
you going to a funeral what happened in
your life and it was just me and normal
clothes yeah tell you something you're
not any better but I like the T-shirt
though it's fat what are you talking
about when I go I know when I go I'm not
like a fashion guy but uh because I
don't really care about the thing either
but I just want to do it so that
you think I actually like fashion oh
yeah that you have a you have a [__]
company I love fashion I love what
clothes can do to somebody I love the
way you could like put things together
and that's why I can't dress really well
people have seen it but then every time
I do it it's just like people expect it
out of me now and I hate it because not
then because if you expecting it out of
you no because if you dress up nice all
the time everybody expects you to dress
nice all the time
like if you don't they're like oh what's
going on with your life but if you put
them in very lowest standards right
that's all they expect out of you so
whenever you do do it that's why when I
have sex with my wife the worst sex ever
I specifically say you will you you will
never come
right
ever I don't care
only I'm enjoying this and you are all
right yeah wow that sounded way
different that's not what I meant what I
meant is that I put my her expectations
low when I do something it's amazing
yeah she does it all the time like I'll
like do the dishes and she goes you did
the dishes
yeah
I'm a good husband
you know on Reddit there was a whole
thread about me and her where they were
saying like they were they had all these
clippings of me and her on this podcast
yeah and like other things that we're
doing that she's clearly in an abusive
relationship and she doesn't know how to
escape is this a real thing like a real
thing already wow like she's in an
abusive relationship she doesn't know
how to escape and we need to help her
oh I get it
because you look at me and you look at
her I get it yeah but she did this
voluntarily yeah she loves me all right
that's nice you too
yeah I um I appreciate it how did you
meet how did you meet your wife was in
high school it was a Oh you guys are
high school sweethearts what the [__]
yeah
that's hella tight dude you don't ever
actually get to see a lot of that yeah
but people people always say that and
then they
um but of course it's hard like you know
we had we broke up many times uh we
broke up with her she Broke Girls both I
don't believe that but go ahead she
definitely left you hey man
don't tell me she's like could you stop
listening to that [__] song for the
past three months I'm so sick of it I
can't
ABC ABC
s
[__] repeat it
half the [__] part of the beginning
[__]
what was the first time you guys broke
up
um or in high school in high school we
broke up several times in college uh we
went to different colleges so we broke
up several times there was the reason
you guys broke up the first time in high
school
um just stupid stuff it's always stupid
stuff
um like we'll fight about colors or
whatever
you know like stupid things like high
school stuff like uh we'll go we're like
oh that's teal and then she's like no
that's green or whatever
and you're like I'm done with this
relationship
that is it that was that was all it took
yeah I really like those flowers it's a
weed idiot get out of my face you're
dead to me
it's like what the [__] I I just said it
was a flower dandelion dummy the [__]
out of my face I'm getting new [__]
a [__] that knows the flowers name yeah
yeah
um dude you did I feel really bad about
this but
this one time I don't know there's one
that
um I was so angry at her
that I made her
walk on the highway
that is very untaiwanese man of you
genius brain farts let's face it with
coffee starting at five dollars and our
bank accounts always somehow always
depleting we are officially entering the
dupe station most products do the same
thing but are priced differently solely
based on the brand name so a good
duplicate or dupe is crucial for getting
the highest quality at the best price
one dupe you definitely shouldn't sleep
on is raycon wireless earbuds because I
love them so much I use them when I'm
jogging uh working out kickboxing going
to sleep listening to adult podcast they
are always on me especially when I
travel because I love the fact that they
have eight hours of play time uh noise
isolation for sure awareness mode and a
whole bunch of other stuff go to
buybraycon.com
brain today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by
raycon.com slash brain to score 15 off
once again that's by raycon.com
slash brain
I
don't know I know how to do math there
on that one Taiwan if you guys know like
this General stereotype is it's like
Taiwanese men are the sweetest yeah we
are like they are the sweet that's
probably when Asian girls talk about
like the type of guy that they want they
never say they wanted to look like
comedies guys because they all look
stupid weird but
no it's coming from a guy who has a
shirt made of an ocean
what the hell and what the [__] is this
orange [__] one piece it's an anime
it's not helping my case so we have
I'm really cool I swear but people
always say like every like Asian girls
will say in the Asian Community it's
like go date a Taiwanese guy because
they're very sweet okay so to hear that
you did some Korean [__] is crazy to me
yeah I've never done it because I'm a
decent human being but yeah why did you
do that
would I this is why I also I think
Opposites Attract because I really she
was kind of crazy too and she's Korean I
understand yeah so then I think I like
that but then sometimes they do too much
and I'm like I can't have this around me
it's too much so go walk out the freeway
get out of here go go walk off you're
crazy I'll go pick you up let me tell
you this story
when I was when I was younger right I
only uh
sympathize and empathize with you
because my mom has walked on the freeway
so much like
so okay so they're used to it right it's
like their thing like whenever like if
you're ever in a car with a Korean girl
and you piss her off she's like just
drop me off right here I don't give a
[__] they'll say that in a plane [__]
drop me off right here it's like dude
we're in the sky yeah what are you
talking about give me a buoy I'm ready
dude my mom literally when my dad was on
the freeway she goes I want to get off
she's screaming and my dad's like are
you [__] crazy we're in the middle of
a freeway she opens the door as the car
is going on the [__] freeway do we
have the same mom my mom did that [__]
too what the [__] is that and then my
dad has no choice but to stop yeah it
happened another time where I wasn't
there and she was walking on the freeway
and I get a call from the cops yeah
right
I'm like hey who is this I was like
hello like this is the you know this is
Elk Grove Police whatever whatnot we
have your mom she's with us right now
and I'm like she's supposed to be at
work what are you doing with my mom
right now like well your mom was walking
on the freeway I was like okay I
understand
I'm sorry you don't need to explain
anymore I I understand and they're like
well we found on the freeway so we have
her here at this Walmart we'll stay with
her until you can come pick her up I was
like okay I I'll go get her and I
literally go pick her up I'm like why
why do you keep walking on the freeway
and in Korean she's like don't say a
[__] word
just take me to work I just drop her off
at work that my dad I remember what he
said he goes I guess you found yourself
your mom huh where was she huh being a
crazy person why are you just walking on
the free did you walk here you got your
son to pick you up oh you must feel good
about yourself this is in public this is
like in the store and there's like a
customer just looking at wigs
[__] Asian people are nuts dude she's
walked on the freeway so much yeah how's
your mom walking on the freeway not it
wasn't if it was Taiwan she always gets
out the car like on the
are just on the drive on the go and
she's left so many times like it from
the car what did your dad say
don't just be yelling like you're used
to be yelling sometimes huh flowers just
like the same [__] that you do it's a
family trailer autistic he's like I said
it was Green
that's where I got it from
Taco guys
yeah
yeah so your family's crazy dude but I
think all Asian family you know are you
crazy this is one thing
um I don't know we're just going on
tangible but I remember my I remember
this one time I was at my grandma's
house and then um
you know they yell all the time it's
just always yelling so I yelled a lot
like when I was younger too and that's
why we broke up me and my wife but um
but uh I'll hear like loud banging and
usually my mom just be banging on hidden
stuff you know and I'm like why is it
not stopping and then I go outside my
mom is banging her head into the cement
wall like 30 times is your mom my mom
dude I swear to God like full-on again
blood coming out just banging on the
dick
[Laughter]
so the wall yeah but my dad literally
sent me a video she goes your mom has
lost her mind she's crazy yeah once
again what does he end it with I need to
find you a new mommy he keeps saying
this [__] I'm gonna stop calling it
mommy and also I'm old now this is
enough he sent me a video of her with
like a like a steel chair yeah steel
chair like the WWE ones yeah
she was digging it on banging on her
[__] head yeah dude we have the same
mom
some of the things I've been thinking
about when you say like because they not
everybody do that too and my mom most
people don't you don't think yeah I
think it's just our parents
there's one thing this is her signature
move you know how like in like uh like
video games yeah yeah this is one of her
moves if you don't down now up down a
yeah then she will slide on the wall
with her back and then scream at high
[__]
like high [__] like for like 30 seconds
like somebody sniped her from a distance
[Laughter]
oh
so dramatic yeah that's what I heard it
moves I don't know what we're talking
about but it's funny my mom's signature
move dude her up down left right
triangle square R1 R2 he said she would
go say that she's running away to Korea
and then she would go hide somewhere in
the house so we can't find her
she goes we're
supposed just the garage like [__]
it's the [__] garage I could see you
again that [__] hurts though you just
turned the flashlight on in the garage
and you see your eyes
[__] nut bag she's also planting
tomatoes
don't worry it's a tomato okay I just
make a tomato I do one time
this girl this lady
she [__] literally we I couldn't find
her at all in the house yeah didn't know
where she was at she [__] tricked us
because she knows that I always go to
the garage and that's where she is and
she's like I'm gonna be smart you'll
never find me so she [__] slept in
the backyard in like the like squash
patch and I didn't know until like the
next day I saw something move in the
back I run out to the backyard it's my
mom and she has like 8 000 mosquito
bites all over oh my god dude she sleeps
on the outside just because she wanted
to [__] teach us a lesson but I'm
like you lost
to the bed
with air conditioning yeah
your face is [__] up well why did you
go outside to teach you and your brother
because she wanted to scare us because
she thought we're gonna look for her oh
yeah yeah I fell asleep
I just woke up what the [__] and then
you see this creature come out from the
squash blossoms
I guess you learned your lesson now but
the [__] is that I got scared dude when
you see somebody with like 400 mosquito
bites on their face it's hideous yeah
that's that's the type of [__] family
trauma I go through your family's weird
too
yeah that would all make sense I can't
believe you or somebody who used to
raise your voice you don't even seem
like that type I used to yell like
really loud me too I don't do it anymore
you have me do why did you why did you
also it's because your dad and stuff did
it my dad did all the time and and I and
my I mean my mom who did both but I
think it's because of that like because
I thought that just everybody does it
like that yeah it's not yeah I didn't
know that you did that I really didn't
know how to communicate communicate like
normally until the recent years like the
past 10 years I learned slowly every day
I go you don't have to be loud you don't
have to bang your head against someone
you don't have to bang your head so you
have to scream we you know I talked
about this too where
um Muriel and I like we grew up in very
different households right but she also
grew up with the Korean family so she
had a certain amount of this but my
family was a little more extreme like
you go into my house there's holes on
the wall everywhere because you'll just
be punching holes in walls like it's
normal yeah you know I'm angry bomb okay
what's for dinner you know it's not like
we had to do this [__] so one time you
know Mario was like pissing me off and
we were getting into a heated [__]
argument I'm like I'm so sick of this
[__] and like there's like this little
her eye cream it was like this big like
I shoot you not like this big and I
[__] threw it on the floor oh no it's
small right and this little thing just
went and it shattered everywhere and
then she just she was like I can't I
can't be in this house and I'm like it
was just eye cream
I was so confused right she goes you're
scaring me I'm like it's eye cream yeah
in my mind I might you don't just throw
like little tiny things
and so she goes no I don't like that
type of stuff you're not supposed to
break things when you get when you fight
like even if I'm being crazy like you
you shouldn't break things that's
frightening and I'm like oh this is not
normal
for me I'm doing better yeah because I'm
not throwing [__] yeah wrecking
everything I didn't punch a hole in the
wall you shouldn't break anything I'm
like oh that makes sense
I'm like oh oh this is not right and
I've never done it since but one time I
I got mad and I threw something again
it's because I remembered how
inappropriate was I had this Nike
windbreaker and I just [__] threw it
I just went
and then I got so mad because it was not
satisfying because yeah yeah it just
kind of floated yeah and I was like I
hate this whole thing I just walked
outside and I went for like a two mile
walk because I was so pissed oh you
don't yell man we don't yell yeah we
don't yell yeah but we you have to learn
that slowly I think I know sometimes I
get I raise my voice it's just how I
grew up in my house yeah and like it's
it's a hard habit to break because your
brain is so like that's just how you did
it yeah and you don't have another way
to do it like when you feel angry or
frustration you go there immediately
it's not like we're like okay I'm gonna
get angry now it's like that's just how
it goes dude the one a very famous
especially because I'm Korean Korean
people love getting angry like that's
like our hobby like if we're not angry
we actually live like [__] shorter
yeah it's supposed to be the opposite
but for Korean people when we yell we
actually live 100 years longer yeah
there's this phrase that my mom says
that all Korean parents know this all
kids know this it goes
and that's literally you die we all die
yeah and I'm like why do you say things
like this yeah she said this to me since
I was a little [__] kid like if I did
if I didn't do my homework oh really you
die I die we all die
it's just math like why don't why do we
have to commit suicide for this we spill
water yeah hey hey you die I die we all
die she said she would say some crazy
[__] [__] yeah and I also think what
I started to realize was
my the reason why they flip out is
because our dads are so stubborn yeah
that they don't listen to anything at
all so the only way they can get through
to them is if they do crazy [__] yeah
yeah and they go okay maybe I should
listen a little bit right so they have
to go to these [__] extremes because
they're so pig-headed they don't listen
to anybody no yeah and so my mom has to
you know and they're angry too is the
thing yes so they so they yell at the
mom and then the mom gets crazy too dude
I just got into a shouting match with my
mom this last weekend yeah and it was
over something small not even small it
was something that I told her to and one
of the things I don't like is that she
never keeps her promises like literally
my mom is the biggest liar I've ever met
in my life
[__] you want to talk about somebody
who lies dude I would tell her some [__]
where like I'll be like okay this is
what's going on with my older brother
right yeah I was like he told me not to
tell you but because I feel like you
should know because this is something
very important but I just want you to
play it cool all right literally I get a
call 10 minutes later I can't believe
you told Mom like what the [__] happened
what happened here can I call her up I
was like what did you Sue I said I told
them that that you told me I was like
what the [__] did I just say
yeah what the [__] she goes what and
then she gets mad at me she goes what's
the problem why are you yelling at me I
get [__] mad so she has this habit of
making promises and [__] breaking
them yeah so
one of the things I told her not to do
was like don't ever bring up money to me
right I was like listen
whenever you need money just ask I'll
give it to you if you need it I got you
right yeah but so she's going to Korea
uh in a little bit and I told her listen
I scheduled this money to go out in the
first of the month that's when the
checks come in so I can give you a
bigger sum right now because I have to
manage my finances
and she goes okay got it [__] calls
me three times in a row where's the
money where's I was like is it the first
of May and I keep telling I was like
look I told you don't mention this stuff
when you say things like this like you
you're basically saying that I'm not
going to take care of you and I told you
I would yeah yeah so that's offensive
she goes I got it I won't bring up money
I promise this won't happen the next day
hey so where's the money
I [__] flip my [__] [__] we get
into this huge argument and we're
yelling at each other and my dad grabs
the phone and that grass he goes what
are you guys fighting about I was like
this [__] lady can't keep her [__]
prop I told her not he goes listen
and he says to me in Korean he goes
you're [__] [__]
and now I'm getting mad at him I'll say
you just call me [__]
because I know that's a thing yeah why'd
you why why am I [__] I was like
she's the one acting like a [__]
idiot he goes listen
I've been married to her
yeah
I can't change her why the [__] do you
think you can change her dude that's
another thing that I try to like realize
how to realize recently like sometimes
you could try to explain something in
the detail like objectively or whatever
in other perspectives but at the end of
the day it's just like that's just how
they are you just got to work around
them yeah he goes she's crazy I go I
know this I gave up yeah I gave up years
ago he goes I'm dead inside
he's like why why do you think you could
change her and I can't because you think
you're better than me it's like
you're better than me I've been trying
to change this
50 years I've known her it's not gonna
happen yeah it's not gonna change give
it up just give it up she's gonna do
this you're gonna say you're gonna give
her something and she's gonna Hound you
about it even if you tell her not to
she's going to do it all the time and so
I go on my on she he gives the phone
back to my mom and I'm like hey you lost
your mind I was like fine [__] it I
don't care anymore you could ask me the
same [__] question over and over
about money as much as you want but the
one thing you have to say to me is this
I was like I need you to say this you
have to say that I understand that I'm
being unreasonable right okay and but
I'll accept it she goes no I don't bro I
[__] busted up laughing
I started crying laughing because of how
ridiculous this woman is yeah she
literally said no I don't I was like dog
you can't even give me a little W yeah
she won't give me anything she goes
and I started crying laughing and my mom
starts dying laughing too
she was like you're not going to beat me
you're not and I think I was laughing
because I lost I think I lost my mind I
just gave up I was like I get it I can't
win it's not going to happen she even
knows she's crazy and she goes I'm not
changing that's so funny dog my mom's
the same way she knows that she just has
to win with like small things like that
but um but what's it called uh yeah but
they they know though they they know
that that that's what it is that's how
you do it she just tries to rip my soul
away every day and like I just sat there
laughing my ass off I'm like okay I give
up I understand this is my dad just
calling me [__] was like how dare
you because you're so like in Korean
it's like pyeongchin like because you're
[__] he's like you're [__]
[__] yeah so and I know like when
you guys hear that some people get
triggered but you know this is cultural
differences like Korean people use this
phrase a lot a lot we're very harsh with
our words so sometimes when I say the
word like people are like you shouldn't
say I keep forgetting because I'm
switching in between two different
cultures and languages right and I'm
pretty sure like in Korean
like we like always like a phrase in
Korean is like you want to die yeah yeah
they say that to like the two-year-old
kid yeah you know so it's very very
harsh right what's that in Thailand in
uh Taiwanese do you guys have phrases
like that yeah
it's the same thing but the thing is
um I feel like but in but Korean culture
if you if two adults say it to each
other I feel like you guys actually do
mean it because you guys fight a lot
like Korean culture I feel like you guys
are more like um I think it was my aunt
or whoever went to Korea and they said
that when they waited in line when she
was in like as far as possible to the
person in front of her in line the
person behind her pushes her like with
her body not like aggressively pushed
but just like nudging shoving her
forward and um I never that that's not
something that is like
and Korean people might get mad when I
say this yeah but I don't care
[Music]
Korean people are basically
Asians that think they have Japanese
etiquette but they're really Chinese
that's a Korean person
they go oh we're better than you yeah
but they're also smoking and spinning on
the floor yeah but the thing is Chinese
people it's actually it's when they the
intention is different like the Chinese
people they just like just hurry up and
go but then I feel like Koreans have a
little more like aggression like why the
[__] are you not moving forward because
right because we're real as [__]
this is why you don't have a real
country yet all right you guys are too
nice
I heard that [__] so much in Taiwan I'm
like what the [__] why does everybody
saying this phrase she goes they're
saying excuse me I'm like you don't have
to yeah you said well how you said I'm
like listen you say that one more
[__] time I'll beat your ass yeah and
I'm Korean so it makes sense
you guys are so nice and polite out
there yeah
literally it's really [__] nice I
think it's because we lost the Civil War
so this your spirit your fighting Spirit
went away it's over yeah
that's why sometimes I'm like I know
what Taiwanese people are now weak but I
just think that sometimes it could come
off like that I it's kindness kindness
yeah it's very very kind the street food
is [__] amazing it's it's weird like
it reminds me of it's Chinese people I
know that sounds offensive this is from
outside Chinese people but but very
Japanese because of like the you know
they they raped us okay yes they did the
colonization yeah
historically accurate yes they're like
you guys integrated Japanese culture I'm
like yeah because they raped us we have
to accept it
we have no choice but at least they
treated you nicer than they treated us
oh yeah yeah no no no no no they did
they I feel like they left on them
because somebody else won I think
Chinese we are done
they just left like we try okay and they
didn't drink it left with Korea we had
to force them out yeah I don't want to
go I'm like you're happy to live
get out right now no
so like you guys were probably because I
know like Taiwanese people they they
like Japan
we like Japanese culture yeah yeah yeah
but we just embraced it we like Korean
culture too that's what's sad about it
like I don't mind like the whole thing
it's just it's sad that people don't get
to experience like Taiwanese culture
because the food is good and we embrace
all the cultures as a thing like Korean
culture K-pop and you know drama but you
guys also [__] up the indigenous
people in Taiwan too just a little bit
I didn't even know there was indigenous
people until I went there oh oh yeah
yeah with the island they look like
Samoans like Polynesian people yeah well
that's the same thing with like any
migration like English that's true
American people to the Native Americans
here it's kind of crazy when I saw that
though yeah and I saw this whole
different culture I had no idea about
and like the language is still there
yeah when we when we're younger we have
to sing it
yo hey I made up a little couple words
but that was the real thing that we have
some Native American as [__] right now I
swear to God those are some of the words
I are actually it all right what did you
say uh-huh what did you say right now
uh-huh
I don't know what I said but it was a
song I swear to God that there were a
few Taiwanese you would know I just know
yeah I should hear that all the time I
don't know what that means let me tell
you something okay that's what it means
oh really yeah I have no idea see I hear
things and I remember it that's funny
you see that I'm a cultural dude no
you're autistic yeah
you know actually I I have like pretty
severe ADHD yeah and uh it started with
Tim taking his testing and then he sent
it over to me to go you can get you can
see a doctor online and you know like a
zoom call and [__] like that you know
when people assess people like usually
it's about like 30 minutes that [__]
assessed me in like two minutes that
[__] was so fast I was a little offended
no she just looks at you yep
yep that's a thousand dollars
like what do you mean
she goes well I turn it on your t-shirts
backwards you have [__] eye boogers
on and also I'm looking at the back of
your head the camera's this way
you're holding two tomatoes
[Music]
on two Tomatoes I'm backwards this way
and my shirt is on the other way she
goes yep how did you know
it's the easiest thousand dollars I've
ever made in my life my ADHD is like
pretty severe and it's weird because
I kind of always they didn't always know
but it's frustrating when I was a kid
because I never understood why I just
couldn't focus because I would see other
people in class and they're just yeah
you know yeah and I would like hate
myself as a kid because I'm like I can't
do this does your parents to go always
like why don't you just focus yeah and I
was like dude
like you got to understand this I can't
do I can't sit still yeah I'm just
moving my [__] like now that Mariel
understands this she can see it now yeah
where she's telling me something really
important like the other day she goes
can I tell you something about my work
and she goes I'm like yeah go ahead and
then my face goes
immediately start drifting off
this way yeah and then I come back and
I'm looking at her she goes you don't
you didn't listen to anything that I
said I'm like I'm so sorry yeah like I'm
trying my best but it reminds me of me
being in college in high school
elementary school all that other stuff
where I could I would look at other
people's study and their focus and I
couldn't do it unless it's something I
enjoy right so that's like a huge sign
that you have like ADHD because I I
basically my argument to her was like
I can focus like I love tomatoes and I'm
not even [__] you I was like I when
I Garden I could guard for hours and she
goes that's actually a big sign that you
had ADHD that's actually one of the the
top things it's like you can only focus
on the things that you enjoy the things
that are important that's not in your
realm of hobbies you can't focus at all
she goes that is the biggest indicator
that you have ADHD and I was using that
as my defense
I was like dude I've been going to
Tomato for like four months she goes
this guy's an idiot
well I only have ADHD I didn't know that
yeah I don't think I knew that yeah
because like we need a certain level of
like uh stimulus but you could also yeah
that's true but you but you could also
focus in things though like in
conversation I noticed that you could
also focus in like a certain topic
because I enjoy this like I love talking
to people I love sharing stories by
certain topics too is that you you're
like oh man like because sometimes I
even forget but you were like pretty
you have that you still have the through
line of of that topic and you could come
back to it and stuff but watch this
though watch you like let's say I don't
know Mario's like I'm like I'm about to
give birth right now and I go okay
tomatoes
my so I started like streaming for like
a month I just did it just to try it out
to see if I liked it it was too
exhausting but it was fun for the fans
so I continued it for about a month and
then people actually finally got to see
they're like oh you do have ADHD because
even when I'm streaming I'm on like 40
different topics for like 40 minutes
just like this bouncing but you know
what the thing is is I I know like to
you and to me that that's the funnest
and easiest way to have conversation but
then
um Carrie will always tell me like hey
this is bad for the listeners because if
it's like exhausting to listen to things
like that but I don't know but like do
we do it for the people who's listening
or what does Kerry uh do for a living
she's a kindergarten teacher
dude
she's like this is my 23rd kid
my permanent kid Jason that's how she
tells you Jason yes Miss Chad
did you eat today yes
okay so what do you do when you put on
your underwear where does the pee hole
go does it go here or there yeah I
thought that was a poop hole
do I show The Neighbors
no wonder she's very patient and she's
patient that makes sense now I have a
friend who's an elementary school
teacher and she's very patient too you
need to be to be like a kindergarten
teacher for sure or this Elementary
School yeah I'm really grateful that
she's you should be dude I am every day
what would happen if she left you like
what was the first thing that you would
do besides cry
first dude I wouldn't care about a lot
of things like I I think a lot more
destructive like way destructive
because I was talking to a friend and um
I wasn't I wasn't like because the
before I started doing stand-up I worked
with my family but before that I was a
before I started working like before I
was waiter and all that I sold drugs
like any other teenager I can't even
imagine I've been selling drugs that is
hilarious I had the best time
is the thing so I think I would want to
sell to because to me you because the
ADHD thing like I can't do any work
so I have to like just sell Joe and have
fun with people but I can't really I
don't think I could do you make a lot of
money selling drugs yeah it was a great
time
I can't imagine you selling drugs at all
I was a fun guy
you don't have to be seriously did you
only sell to your friends or did you
like try to get sales throughout like
with strangers dude okay with the first
okay you're gonna sell me drugs okay I'm
walking around to have a good time not
strangers okay let's see your sales tax
that you [__] loser okay here we go
hey man how's it going do you like drugs
[__] narc
let's be running away right now wait
come back
wait don't say Hey you like drugs like
what the [__]
how did you make a living off of this no
what do you mean they it wasn't me like
they already have like a bunch of people
that gets as you sell weed no eggs Coke
weed yeah oh then you had the whole
cocktail yeah it was just like this
guy's uh house but what I'm saying is
that it makes it I did that for a while
and that kind of [__] up my value of
money because um
I was it came really easy like at that
time and I did it for a bit and then and
I think for like an ADHD and like an
autistic brain you're like oh man that's
easy and no I went to the first Rave I
went to it was EDC when it was 2006 or
2007. I was like 15 or 16 or something
and then we would sneak X in there and
then we'll make like a bunch of money
how much money did you make let's say
per se uh per month I'm just curious
okay here's the thing yeah always wanted
to sell dry
and I never got to do it you never got
to tell drugs I never got this I thought
you would sell drugs okay
I was like they were definitely so drunk
no I feel like everybody
Asians like that look like you and talk
like you I'm like these people sell
drugs too no I I okay first of all I
don't even know what that means but it
sounds offensive I've never sold drugs I
didn't really do drugs I only drink
alcohol because I remember you saying
you came from sac and then not like
everybody I didn't because here's the
thing I'm also very stubborn if I don't
want to do something I don't want to do
something yeah I just never cared for it
okay I only started smoking weed uh in
the last few years because uh it helps
me sleep yeah it has to be for a
medicinal purpose like not because of a
moral thing I just don't like
just not feeling in control yeah I need
to be my life is already chaos yeah if
we're having a conversation I'm smoking
I guarantee you I don't know where I'm
at
100 dude my friend was opening up his
heart to me once about his divorce
for like an hour straight right and the
whole hour I was sitting like pay
attention look like you're paying
attention he he cannot know that you
don't know what the [__] you're talking
about oh my God she's crying he's
opening up his heart oh my God and I
just reach out my hand I put it on a
shoulder I was like put your hand on his
shoulder so he thinks you care he
doesn't know that this is the
conversation I'm having yeah and then
afterwards like two hours later I
snapped out of it I'm like dude what he
said at all all he said was dude thanks
for listening and I'm like I wasn't but
you know what you were there and that's
what's important exactly you were there
that's the most important thing and that
three hours felt like two minutes
pay attention pay attention don't let
him know blink blink
he did it take a breath
figure
why is David doing that why is he saying
it out loud take a breath
not even saying it in my mind
how much money did you make per month on
average
um honestly I never counted but I
remember
in like the four month period this one
summer because we also like
I know Carrie said it but we also like
did stuff like we went into other
people's houses and stuff you did house
rates yeah it was a good time
but I was I was but I was really young
and I was trying to have a good time
and I wanted money
you are such a piece of [__] I know but
the thing is what is with [__]
druggies and raiding homes like you're
not oh by the way I'm just saying I'm
not really judging you because literally
this is like halfway but I'm really not
like that though
how much money did you make in those
four months
um at the very very least
28 000. at the very least I didn't want
to go any lower but at the very least
yeah yeah it's a lot in like four but we
did it for a while for like maybe eight
months or whatever when did you why do
why did you stop
you just felt bad no
[Laughter]
dude I want to do it forever
are you kidding me who wants to stop
that's why you're afraid there's no one
that let's try to make this story really
nice and rounded I was like did you stop
because you became a better person no
dude
hahaha oh yeah oh yeah dude you know
what I saw recently that that was one of
them that me and my friends watched the
Gangnam Style one the parody oh you
remember when it came out I was in
Concordia I was in college and I was
like man actually it was hilarious I
thought of that [__] when I was drunk at
a Korean barbecue and we wrote it that
night and we shot it the next day what
yeah so we didn't sleep dude that's very
efficient that you guys did that it was
me my buddy Dan and my buddy Ed and we
were at a Korean barbecue drunk as [__]
just off of Soju and beer and I was like
dude let's make a [__] parody of this
[__] this is so good I was like I look
exactly like him it'll be [__]
hilarious it's so good I called up
everybody I was like hey you guys want
to be a part of this video but he just
got this new camera guy together did it
the next day ham yep the location and
everything and the movements it that I
feel like it would take a little bit but
you did it one day that it was literally
one [__] day that's crazy it was that
fast wow that's how I used to roll dude
that's what I was motivated before
Tomatoes wow
when I was motivated back in the day if
I wanted to get something done I got it
[__] done it did it didn't matter
what it was wow I would call people up
see if people wanted to work and do this
type of [__] some [__] like that now I
feel like it would take a while like
people have to call like be like hey you
know I mean get that that's crazy that
everybody who has now evolved in their
careers so now we're not as free so
before it was like who knows where this
is gonna go no but I mean people coming
up now like doing YouTube and stuff I
feel like if they would do something
like that it would be you have to plan
it yeah yeah the guys get the camera
things like is this person available is
that that's what I'm saying like doing
your special [__] is not is [__] cake
work dude like I did a whole production
like that in a day yeah like you think
[__] recording somebody standing on
stage talking stupid [__] is hard for me
that's crazy because I literally I'm
trying to plan it right now and it's a
lot like I did [__] two calls already
like a zoom thing like call for what
what do you need to call for just to go
over things I don't [__] no David I
don't know what the things and then
they're like hey we should do a call and
then they set up a whole Google thing
bro and we talk for a little bit but
who's who are you calling my friend is
helping me so he's setting it up with
this production team that he knows and
um we're just talking about the sound
the venue the light the lighting and uh
all that stuff
yeah that's all I'm just saying that
it's hard to do that is what I'm saying
yeah
I like how they make it sound like it's
so difficult maybe it's just me like I
just um it's not that hard yeah
it's really not that hard yeah
it's it's really not hard at all yeah
when are you gonna reshoot it
um well that's the thing yeah I already
talked to uh June something it's in in
San Diego but it's still in the talks so
I haven't you know we haven't said any
details about uh payment or anything but
they did do a proposal and
um we're just talking about it now but
now I'm like wondering about this thing
now well look if your buddy feels very
confident that he could do it I'm pretty
sure he can yeah if it comes out
terrible I'm gonna be so pissed
I'm gonna be so [__] mad your buddy
better have some type of background in
this [__]
yeah but uh because a lot of when are
you gonna start doing stand-up man okay
don't do it to the fans and stuff but I
want to ask you because you've been
doing a lot of food stuff I know you
probably got but I I'm curious about
this were you doing a lot of food stuff
and you went like hiking and stuff
I saw you went on a hike or something
this was like maybe two months ago
whatever the thing is so what's what's
going on this is how good jumbee is
doing I just wanna let you guys know
they're like a short [__] five months
ago he's like yeah start a business it's
hard five months later he's doing
Tomatoes she's a whole lot of everybody
know this guy is probably just looking
at my stories like this fat [__]
over here I just [__] had a child of
[__] I should have kept selling drugs
I'm just [__] God damn it making
jokes what the [__] am I doing
let me tell you this
I
want to do stand up a little bit right
okay but the fire is it's gone it's gone
I feel it I don't know why other brother
I'll tell you this and I don't mean to
be say this because I'm talking myself
up I'm a funny guy yeah like 100 you
know I'm not amazing but I can work
there again and get to a point where I'm
pretty damn good you know yeah
but it's like stand up is such a grind
you if you don't have the fire you're
not gonna do it it's so hard yeah
because I'm like I'm remembering how
hard it was right just like just working
on this Edge just working on yourself 24
7 writing all the time and then I just
go back to tomatoes I'm like why
it's a great
I don't mind like I love that I love
that for you bro I don't mind hosting
because it doesn't require a lot of work
yeah and there's no pressure right right
but for me to try to work like 15 minute
sets this 30 minute says oh this is my
hour that shit's gonna take a lot you
know what honestly I feel like if you
actually do do it and then you actually
see your fans and [__] I think you'll
really enjoy it because it's just so fun
there's no reason there's not a thing
that with your ADHD thing and your
background and what you do that you
don't enjoy it
fun it's just like even to host the
thing or whatever the thing is or just
even to do 10 minutes talking to the
thing I feel like you give yourself too
much I am going to do this though a
hundred percent it's gonna happen this
summer yeah I am going to do a genius
brain comedy show I'm gonna get I'm
gonna just get a small little venue oh
why though what just because I want to
do it okay so like I want you pat a few
other people there and I'm just gonna
host it and I want people to come
through and laugh just so I could do it
yeah and then who knows it might spark
something I don't think so I don't think
this guy I don't think it will spark
something where you host it and if you
don't have a fire but I really think
you'll enjoy it if you're just like but
who knows but tomato is here so tomato
is here Tomatoes here Jimmy is doing
great
who knows what'll happen man like who
knows but let's just say you know what I
don't like this pressure so this guy
this wraps up this episode of the Jesus
spray podcast and my ass is sweating you
could find Jason as Jason everywhere
Please spell it
j-a-s-o-n-c-h-e-n-y I do stand-up comedy
please come see me
um before people realize that is a scam
you could go check out his special on
his channel but he might take it down
and redo it yeah it's actually doing
really decent on the views though it's
not bad I just wanted to make it look
nice but I want people to come out and
see me that's the most thing that's why
I want to take it down because it is
garbage I'm sorry okay it is garbage 100
thank you for the support brother I
really appreciate it I got you I was so
pissed with that [__] game I was like
this is not it this is not it at all
this is terrible I don't know what the
[__] is happening and I like how I said
like you decided like you recorded on
your iPhone and you did so
um very even more disappointing and I
was a joke and it just turned out to be
true
make sure that you guys check out Jason
everywhere he'll be back on this podcast
as per usual
um check out Genie Sprint every Sundays
at 12 p.m uh stay tuned for that genius
brain comedy show it's gonna happen this
summer I'm gonna set it up I'll be
hosting all my [__] funny ass comedy
friends and they'll be doing stand up
come ready to laugh it's going to be
dope I put it out there so I could do it
this is also a sign of ADHD of like
saying that something's gonna happen and
it doesn't happen
I I don't ever do that though yeah I
have ADHD I have it too but don't do
that why do you do that huh because why
do you say things and don't do it just
don't say it then you [__]
okay I just opened up to you about my
problems and you just [__] therapist
me like your therapist did you
my heart hurts you are stupid
every Sunday at 12 p.m we'll see you all
next time peace